let's not ask any questions let's not
talk about anything of note
let's make collider regret this yeah i
think find people to blame
let's play my parents
i'm going to ask what i think is a
terrible question uh i've been asked
this many times before and i always
am uh somewhat angry that question that
i'm sure you've gotten a thousand times
where do your ideas come from well they
come from all over the place
like some historical thing i read about
there's so many sources
it's kind of endless but what about you
well i mean uh the thing that i've
noticed over the years is that
the main source of my ideas is me being
disappointed in something
i also have a little bit of adhd so when
i see scenes
sometimes my brain will go the scene
should go here and then this should
happen and then this should happen and
this should happen
and i'll realize that like five minutes
of a movie has passed and i'm not even
really paying attention to what's
happening i'm just working out some new
version
i did this project called oblivion song
and the basis for that was i heard
somebody lamenting the fact that jack
kirby
had never had like a substantial run on
batman
and i was thinking you know i wonder
what jack kirby would do
if he had done you know a solid run on
batman
you know he'd probably incorporate some
new god stuff and you probably have
batman using all kinds of crazy
technology and give him all kinds of
different gear
and the basis of that eventually
spiraled into this project oblivion song
that i do that's about this guy that
you know runs around on rooftops with a
cape it all came from someone saying hey
why didn't jack kirby do some batman
that would have been cool
you know people have been bugging me to
uh to
do something with batman and and i uh
woke up one day and and realized i was
29
which meant that i was about to turn
older than batman
and just kind of told myself i will not
let this happen
and so i made him the impossibly distant
age of
50 and and turned that into darkness
i think you would agree that batman kind
of lives in the shadow of frank miller
now
it's it's it's kind of a it's it's it's
you know it's a never-ending
write that down you know may we quote
you on that
sure please do there's there's batman
before frank miller and batman after and
i think that you introduced the concept
of this grim and gritty and scary dark
knight that you know
still prevails to this day and i think
that's why we're never going to get a
batman movie that doesn't have a guy in
a jet black rubber suit
uh speaking with a scary gravely voice i
feel like that's not necessarily what
your intent was but i think that's how
other people
you know pull that through does he have
to have fake muscles
i think that a batman doesn't work
unless he has uh fake abs molded into
his chest piece i think that that is the
really the
the thing that really strikes fear into
the heart of
evil doers but uh this isn't a question
i just wanted to challenge
you frank miller to doing at least one
more batman project
where you bring back dick sprang
inspired
brightly colored gags athletic batman
just to show people hey look guys
there's still more to be done with
batman you don't always have to be doing
this
i would love to do the rainbow batman
no no not rainbow batman nobody likes
rainbow batman uh the other
cool no i'm kidding mr picky piggy picky
i mean excuse me
no rain but zebra batman's okay right
zebra batman is great
that's on point rainbow batman i think
is a bridge too far
watch it you're bouncing around too much
it's all right
stretchered gyro stabilized
cool what is this thing
you're a writer artist and so i wanted
to get a little bit of information on
like what is your
process of tackling a story like is it
is it all purely visual do you actually
write scripts for yourselves i know a
lot of people that are writer artists
that
don't like how how do you handle that
aspect of the work putting together the
story i do very much
as as any writer would i jot down
notes and the scenes we'd like to see
mostly i work on the spine of the story
itself
but as i do that i'll i'll i'll just
draw a line
off the the you know the central notes
and and make a few notes of of something
in particular i know that could be drawn
from that that would be really juicy
but i i have the story
outlined before i draw anything but then
i tend to start drawing
and you know blocking in each scene and
and
working out the dynamics of of of what's
going
on however i will interrupt that
when it breaks into dialogue when it's a
dialogue scene the words are in command
yeah and and the and the characters are
are responding to or projecting the
words um
but here i'm very very uh you're curious
about what you're approaching
i wanted to be a comic book artist so i
i uh you know i do a little bit of
doodling here and there
i very quickly realized that i don't
have the patience and don't have the
talent
to handle that side i try to build
exciting scenes because
uh i think that the worst thing you can
do as a writer is give an artist boring
things to draw
oh yeah yeah it just it's it's
it's high crimes in the comics world
it's a crime to the reader it's a crime
to everybody
if you can't take a talking head scene
that is five pages and squeeze it down
to one or two
what are you doing what are you doing uh
and if you're an artist out there that's
watching this and you get a five page
talking head scene by all means
just cram that into two or three pages
like no one cares
your writer might be mad for like a day
but then when the book comes out people
are saying they like it and he's taken
all the credit for it it's fine
but they'll be happy in the end but yeah
i try to build exciting scenes and then
i uh
uh i just try to like kind of come up
with tethers to
pull those into a story so sometimes
i'll sit down to write an issue and i'll
just be like i don't know this guy
gets a knife shoved through his head and
he falls into a building and explodes
let's make that work
yeah you know and i try to figure out a
way to get to that point i like to think
of myself as a
disgruntled artist that is uh uh writing
is like a
uh consolation prize for what i wanted
to do
you're good company there because of
course the classic one of all time is
harvey kurtzman
beyond that archie goodwin and jim
shooter at marvel comics
they'd all lay out the stories that they
that they were writing
well can we can we wrap this interview
up now i'm getting compared to archie
goodwin and
uh harvey kurtzman and jim shooter i
think i think we're done here
that's that's enough for me
remember me i think the way that you
have taken the characters of batman and
daredevil
and uh fundamentally changed them into
your own vision in a way that really
kind of set the stage for everything
that came after
i think is uh uh again you know
something
more people should be striving to do and
it's just you know
absolutely amazing and impressive thing
i'm not gonna apologize for this
compliment
but uh um you sit down to take over
daredevil for example
yeah like what's in your head like how
do you look at that landscape and go
okay we need an electra
i'm going to take bull's-eye and turn
him into somebody who's actually serious
and deadly
like how do you nuts and bolts just kind
of jump in and go okay this needs to
happen and this needs to happen like
what's the thought process there
when i was 24 years old the thought
process process was
oh my god i get to do a mobile comic
book and i meet the deadlines
the first thing i thought was i'm going
to turn this into a crime comic
because i decided my mission was to
bring back the crime comic
the one that wasn't involved in
mythology so i
brought back a kind of a cartoon
underworld and just
stole from will eisner shamelessly and
and
and and and uh you know eventually when
i got the writing end of it
you know brought in elektra and turned
it into a gothic romance that was when i
decided it was going to be one big long
story
that one was a real epic journey for me
uh dark knight was much more consciously
a novel
because i had started it as actually a
much much darker book than it
turned out to be there was no robin in
it or any or anything and it was much
more of a
kind of a grim batman comes back
and he's he's a little too berserk for
the world and basically he
wound up getting got killed by cops
but as i was working on it the character
particularly batman just started talking
back on me
and and i think mainly because because i
introduced
the carrie kelly character with her
around all of a sudden he had a reason
to be alive
it was like opening a suitcase superman
came in
because originally superman wasn't made
and it has
what i believe is a very affirmative
ending he's gone from talking about the
best
death he could have to a good life that
changed pretty radically
when you were starting with walking dead
uh-huh i'm throwing your own question
back at you
sure how'd you come up with it
uh yeah i mean again uh going back to
you know the comment about where my
ideas come from it was uh
i was watching the romero movies the
original trilogy was the first
did uh night of the living dead not a
living dead i saw that when i was when i
was a little kid
well i don't know when i was quite young
night of the living dead was in the
public domain
and so late at night on this broadcast
channel they would just play night of
the living dead and so
i actually got to see it on tv with
commercials
like in the middle of the night one time
for the first time uh so that was my
first experience with it
but uh um you know i was uh uh
you know watching dawn of the dead and
day of the dead
and both of those movies end with
characters getting into helicopters and
flying off never to be seen again
and i was like the only thing i want
more from this movie is to see what
happens to these people next
every one of the romero movies featured
a completely different cast
and there was a time progression so if
the world was a character in those
movies you got to see a little bit more
of the world progress through time
but you never got to really follow those
characters i i wish these romero movies
would never
end but that's not a thing that's going
to happen so i'm going to do the zombie
movie that never ends
and and that'll be walking dead of
course i did this at a time when every
comic book i've ever done had been
cancelled after like
five or six issues so it was uh uh
you know quite foolish of me to set out
on a project that would last a long time
uh not having ever done that before
wonderful story
thank you frank after all that
after me trying to blow your head off
stab your heart out happily ever after
together
you can kill me i couldn't kill you i'll
take that as a sign
hard-boiled is one of my favorite
projects that you've ever done thank you
this may sound laughable to you but that
was a real challenge as a writer
see he laughs well no no i mean correct
me if i'm wrong it kind of you know like
you give
jeff a script and he's like okay i'm
going to do 17 000 different things with
this that you didn't necessarily expect
and then you get the pages back and you
have to go
well i have to make this make sense like
is that is that basically the process or
am i
talking out of school yeah yeah they're
more or less yeah
i mean the thing is i had i had
originally
written him a real short story in the
vein of harlan allison
very bleak scary futuristic
story and the artwork came back and now
jeff
he's an absurdist and and and uh
this stuff just gorges out of him this
unbelievable artwork and i thought what
am i gonna do
if i used the script that i had written
it's just going to be the most overdone
tedious thing in the world but i was
sitting there with that
unbelievable first page where he's just
blown to pieces and
he's holding his guns you know nixon is
and
my breakthrough was the opening line
which is just come and get it
you bum there's you know
there's no like stanley big captions or
anything around but
that set the time for how i collaborated
with him on that book
i got him back on big guy because there
i just loaded on the words with a shovel
just to you know just to show him
you told him um now i think uh
hardboiled is i guess a a really great
lesson again for comic book writers out
there like know when to get out of the
way
oh yeah uh when your guys going crazy
just stand back and enjoy it
well also also let allow yourself to be
in this case the silent partner
let him take center stage and he's the
show like what do you look for
when you're going to be writing a book
for someone else it's always because i i
really
you know like their work a lot jeff
darrow comes to mind but this sort of
built-in cabbage
one of the most extraordinary talents
i've ever encountered but with david
masakeli
i was coming back to the daredevil book
and i really liked the work he was doing
on it already and he and i got into an
exploration together
he was really at the very beginnings of
what he would have to offer
just the leap with him between the
daredevil work we did
and batman year one was extraordinary
the best collaborations for me are the
ones where we
come in we have a very good time and we
both walk away from it enriched
having learned from each other um
cincavich for instance he
taught me to lose some fears
that i didn't even know i had he's so
brilliant
that he takes it in as soon as he sees
it but he always has his eyes open
and he's very acutely aware what's going
on in the illustration field
what's going on in film and everywhere
else
and and since is also highly intelligent
so he's processing it super fast
and and on top of that he's the the
thing that i cannot imitate is that he's
got
the most unnatural drawing skill you can
ever
yeah that helps you should see the
sketches man i'm telling you
i've seen some he did some uh walking
dead covers for us
oh great sending us design sketches and
things and it was just like uh can we
stop now this stuff is amazing
but meanwhile also i mentioned dave
gibbons here too because
what you've got is is really an
overwhelming intelligence
and a capability to to organize
space and to deliver the most ridiculous
idea in the world with a straight face
the martha washington series got more
and more ridiculous the more dave and i
collaborated
all of a sudden these phallic laser
cannons pointed
pointed at planet earth
i knew he could pull them off without
even a smile
and and it would work
not mine man where
is it made not mine man i told you i'm
clean
i do want to ask you a little bit a
little bit about hollywood just because
i've had some fun experiences in
hollywood and i know you've had some fun
experiences in hollywood there's no
other kind of yeah
yeah exactly what was your first
experience
i know you were invited to write the
robocop movies but like is there any fun
anecdotes about like on the set of
robocop or anything where you were just
like what in the hell is going on
it was one of the wildest adventures i
ever had
because i had no idea what the hell i
was doing coming in
when i sat down with john davison the
producer i watched the robocop movie
then i watched a bunch of other movies
and
i know i just i just went wild coming up
with my stories and i
i came up with some of the most
unproducible stuff you've ever seen
it was really a learning process i i
came in with with just a
gigantic amount of material i was
inspired by the first movie because i
thought there was stuff in it that was
really marvelous
but mostly i was just in the new world
thought i could get away with anything
found out that i couldn't and and uh i
kept trying to pull it back to my
original script because it was as it was
being pulled
in a different direction and i was the
most tenacious little son of [ __ ] in
the world
and you know that that i i would not let
go to the last
cut all through it i thought we were
going to win an oscar with a damn thing
you know
and it's and it's a but it was i i can
only look back on it with absolute
fondness
because you know it's just an amazing
education
and and it was a rejuvenation for me to
to to
to really uh go back to boot camp
okay now i gotta ask to clear that one
back at you oh
gosh um no i don't know i mean i've
definitely been on
on the walking dead set many times being
explained to
like why i'm only getting 200 zombies
instead of 4 000 zombies
uh you know like hey and i and i've you
know
i was very much a novice when i started
writing on the on the show and so it was
you know tons of production meetings
where they would sit there with my
scripts going why did they let this get
this far this is never getting shot
you cannot do this like we're we have to
shoot these episodes in eight days like
this is you know not gonna work it's a
frustrating thing because then you have
to go back and go okay well i guess i
have to write
what is in my opinion a lesser version
what you realize as you
get a little bit more accustomed to it
is that the production people know that
what you're trying to do is going to be
terrible
because you're you're trying to eat uh
an entire pizza
as opposed to you know eating eating
eating a slice which you'll actually
enjoy
uh and so they're actually kind of
protecting you from yourself
which is a fun thing to learn after four
seasons took me four seasons
with a feature you're dealing with such
a fixed unit
with a series i i've seen the difference
and it's so much more fluid
yeah cursed that's the one you're
talking about right yeah the show was
great
i am a firm believer that too many
movies look exactly the same
and that modern movie making could use a
little bit of a kick in the pants
i think the spirit was a spectacular
movie that you did an amazing job on
do you think you will ever direct
another movie um
only if i get the opportunity that's
something that you would enjoy you'd be
open to doing it again
with the information and experience that
you know that i've gathered um i'd uh
i i know that i'd enjoy it on top of
welcoming the challenge personally i
have seen in other interviews you
mentioned that you have another sin city
thing cooking that is possibly a western
is that thing still cooking can i expect
that soon
you can't expect it soon but it's
cooking
all right that's that's like 50 percent
of the answer i want and i'll take it
all right
that's all you get man was this as much
fun for you as it was for me
that was a lot of fun are we best
friends now could we get on the phone
and talk sometime
absolutely all right i think that
sounded accurate but uh
okay maybe he was being honest all right
well thanks so much for doing this man
what you just said maybe i said i said i
said
there seemed to be some honesty there
i'll take it oh okay
this man has been hurt he's been hurt i
tell you
i think it shows in my work frank
you